which is the harder gig for you is it
being the sideline reporter or working
on Dancing with the Stars
sideline reporter yeah totally because
you have to deal with the elements you
have to study so much there's a lot more
guys on the field than there are dancers
on Dancing with the Stars and you know
Dancing with the Stars for me I'm just a
huge fan of reality show in general I
love them all and I feel like I just ask
what I would ask on my couch for
football it's just I've never played you
don't want to screw up there's so many
things to know going into the game so
you've got a bit more on edge you've
also you're dealing with the occasional
loose cannon when you're working in the
NFL you've had this threat memorable
Richard Sherman interview where he just
goes off
yeah just goes off and you are caught
there not knowing I think you know what
he's talking about initially a lot of
people didn't know what he was talking
about it's a fun moment let's take a
look
well I'm the best corn and again when
you try me with a sorry receiver like
Crabtree don't you long gig don't you
ever talk about me
[Applause]
it's talking about you Crabtree don't
you open your mouth [ __ ] Beth are you on
the Senate for you real quick
I don't be alright
and Joe back over to you
[Applause]
one is I you know you always make fun
about your head or you know your hair or
whatever like they pull away and they
just do a single of Richard Sherman and
you can still see my damn nose in the
camera I'm like come on right the next
one is just my transition there Joe
throws it to me I thought I was gonna
get a third question and I couldn't have
been more awkward which grosses me out
about myself that what are you table I
thought you know well there's nothing
else to say I thought you had the
perfect response which was you reacted
the way we would if a volcano blew up we
would just look at it and all in wonder
and then say back to you it was so
awesome and then I sat there after he
walked away and I just thought oh my god
oh my god this is gonna go viral and
then my phone started going off and it
grabbed it and it was my boyfriend at
the time and I was like hello and I'm
literally on the field there's confetti
everybody's going nuts and he's like
babe oh my god I can't believe that just
happened I said I have to go why on the
field I can't believe this just happened
but it was awesome
you